on Prime crime I went downstairs and his
face was covered in do you know what
they were hitting him with a guy the
desperate search for a husband and
father I think you know exactly who did
this and I think you're scared and the
investigation that leads to an
unthinkable conclusion Chris Durant
calls dispatch and that turns out to be
an important uh moment right
there
[Music]
hey there everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
do a deeper dive into the most
high-profile and memorable True Crime
cases what starts out as a terrifying
home invasion turns into something else
entirely tus County 911 what's your
emergency I have a home Invision my
niece has tied up she's tied up she is
tied up and
dead it's February 20th 2015 in Titus
County Texas Ginger kerson is on the
phone with police explaining that
someone broke into the home of her niece
I am untying her I can't get theise what
is the victim's name uh Samantha Wolford
according to Wolford she managed to
break free from her restraints and call
her mom who then contacted kerson to to
come to the house during the attack her
five children were all asleep however as
for her husband the father of three of
those kids Ernest Ernie ibera Jr he's
nowhere in sight he's saying that they
hid her husband in the face about five
times and drove him out police quickly
arrive on the scene so walk me through
what happened I don't honestly know what
happened okay I was in bed asleep okay
then we heard a noise and the second I
was able to open my eyes somebody
grabbed me and jerp me out of the bed
and slam me down on the ground and
started tiing me up didn't recognize
anything about they had black masks on
black shirts black pants every inch of
skin was
covered home invasions are rare among
average people because of the fact that
there's so much risk involved right
because when you come into a home
invasion you're coming in with force
with weapons you're holding people at
gunpoint the situation can easily spiral
out of control it was a very harrowing
tale and very
dramatic then when they dragged me
downstairs cuz they had to him
downstairs and they were separating us I
went downstairs and his face was covered
in BL do you know what they were hitting
him with a
guy at one point Samantha says they
bring her downstairs and have uh her
stand in front of him while they say how
can you not appreciate what you have
here you have this beautiful woman here
but how can you not appreciate this how
could he treat her so badly uh that they
exposed her and they used her to taunt
him while they continued to beat him why
would someone attack this couple and
where exactly is Ernie let's take a step
back after meeting in a tattoo shop in
2008 Samantha and Ernie began dating
Samantha already a mother of two ends up
having three more children with Ernie
and the pair wed in 2014 yet things
between the two weren pitcher perfect I
don't think that uh they had a very good
relationship uh it looked to me like he
was doing um everything he could to keep
uh the family financially afloat he was
working two
jobs she was not working so what was she
doing I've always wanted to be an
actress I think it is so much fun one of
the most amazing forms of art ever to be
able to express yourself that way
Wolford spent her days posting numerous
videos on her own YouTube channel when
you first saw the YouTube videos you
know it was more like you know
personable and she was trying to do
howto types of videos hey guys I'm doing
a makeup tutorial today um it's my first
one so don't be too harsh But as time
went on you saw her videos become much
more darker much more complaining about
her relationship really putting her
personal life on Front Street hey
YouTubers today a lot of shit pissed me
off so you guys get to listen to it his
dad's not having a whole lot to do with
this
pregnancy and that sucks I'm kind of
screwed as far as dating goes because I
date losers I think that's a had this
perception that other people really
cared about her life and she fed into
that perception I think this was a
source of excitement for her and she
wanted attention the problem is is that
this really developed into this kind of
tunnel vision for her it was her only
focus and her family was really left to
the Wayside what do you think of me
making YouTube
videos well I guess I don't mind takes
up a lot of time
this desire for Samantha to become a
YouTube star or some kind of
influencer really started to impact the
relationship between her and Ernie and
Ernie felt a little bit
forgotten not going to lie to cigarette
oh yeah I forgot about cuz you got that
fucking iPad in your
hands at least you're paying attention
but only because it's fucking hilarious
ass
episode coming up Samantha sits down
with with authorities and she realizes
who may be behind this attack I feel
like there's something he hasn't been
telling me but I don't know what what's
your good fan tell you I think it's
something to do with his
dad they would have to either be
familiar with the place to be able to do
all that and know where they were
asleep in February 2015 a authorities in
Titus County Texas are confronted with a
strange situation a woman named Samantha
Wolford explains that unknown massed
Intruders broke into her home attacked
her and her husband Ernie ibera and then
kidnapped him while her kids were asleep
upstairs it's what Wolford remembers
though about the comments from the as
salant that provides a new clue did you
hear them say anything else besides what
you told us they said that it was
because of his dad and because of his
dad yeah okay they said his dad knocked
on someone and got their man thrown
Behind Bars and now they were taking
revenge and taking someone from him
could Ernie's father somehow be mixed up
in all of this as Wolford later tells
detectives she thinks he just might be
his dad has a problem with getting
involved in things that he don't need to
be getting involved with such drugs as
law enforcement worked to check out this
lead they notice that some things are
off I'm not really seeing a whole lot of
blood though for somebody that was
pistol whipped scene's not really making
sense she's
telling no everybody's wearing all black
black shoes no identify marks on them
there's also the matter of a bound
Wolford calling her mom my mother was
the first number on my call list I just
used my face and so instead of calling
that 91 for help you called your mother
how do you press 911 with your face well
how did you dial your mother with your
face I didn't dial my mother I just
pushed the first thing that was on there
it had just happened to be my mom I
think you know exactly who did this I
think the story is made up about about
the uh your daddy his daddy and and and
stuff like that I think you know I think
you know exactly who did this and I
think you're scared Samantha sees
herself as an actress but I think that
she EX exaggerates her own abilities and
investigators really see right through
her the only other
thing okay say I knew you know you know
Sam you know I'm not here lying to you
you know I know the only other thing I
know and I don't even know if I know
okay but it's a suspicion okay I've been
up at the hospital with my friend
Charlotte okay and she's got a guy there
and I swear to God I cannot go up there
that I said any of this okay because
they have a lot of friends around here
in my life will be in a lot of nature
okay I have a problem talking to my
friends about our problem and he gets to
talking
about how a man shouldn't treat a woman
that way and how you don't do those
things to a person and he's going to
deal with the situation I didn't take
him seriously okay you see Sam you know
who did this okay what who is this guy
his name is John John who his Facebook
is John
Rebel as time went on her story started
to change because reality is when you
tell the truth the truth doesn't change
and when the details start to switch up
that is definitely a cue for law
enforcement that there's more happening
here and that they need to dive deeper
what did you say when he said he's going
to take care of that problem I just
laughed at him I thought he was joking
so now all of a sudden why you bringing
him out cuz you know that it was him why
do you know it was him I just
have this feeling like it
was up next we find out who this John
Rebel is and also what happened to Ernie
they never told me why they just told me
that they were going to fuck this dude
[Music]
up but the evidence we're found on the
scene it's just not matching I don't
think you I don't think you harm this
boy but I think you know who did
it's February 2015 and young mother and
YouTuber Samantha Wolford admits to
Texas police she may know who's behind
the Abduction of her husband Ernie ibera
she explains that one day she had
complained of her marital problems to
her friend's boyfriend who cryptically
said he was going to deal with the
situation a statement that at the time
Wolford said she didn't take seriously
this man was identified as Jonathan
Sanford now Jonathan Sanford had
recently been released from prison for
molesting his cousin starting in junior
high he enjoyed you know shaking kids
down for lunch money he's just that kind
of guy and he's really Unapologetic
about anything he did um illegal wrong
immoral police quickly arrest Sanford as
well as his brother-in-law Jose Antonio
Pon Jonathan Sanford and Jose Pon were
arrested the following morning and they
were arrested because of information
that Samantha finally disclosed to law
enforcement she had previously described
that there were three of them so I think
law enforcement believed that there was
at least one more person involved police
also apprehend Octavius Lamar ryes who
Sanford enlisted for the attack on Ernie
Octavius ryes was from nearby town of uh
Pittsburgh he had been in the military
he was using
drugs amphetamine specifically he wasn't
doing anything productive and that's
kind of what put him in this situation
pretty quickly after the sheriff's
department detained and arrested uh Jose
Pon and Jonathan
Sanford those two individuals
talked Sanford decides to open up to
police and explains how and why they
attacked
Ernie
Samantha talking about
her relationship with me and Jay and my
sister-in-law and all that and me trying
to talk to her and help her out and all
that because she seems like a good
person to me she was explaining to me
how he treats the kids and all that if I
ever see it or if I happen to be around
or if I ever see her with bruises or the
kids with bruises that so yeah I said
I'd whoop his ass I didn't say i'
hospitalize I'mma put you down and make
sure you can't come back up and who my
ass that I'm walking away it's almost
like his attitude was well you caught me
so I'm just going to lay it out there
for you Sanford recounts that after
kidnapping ibera they took him to the
woods and killed him so Jonathan Sanford
led the the sheriff to where the body
was Sanford hon and ryes had taken Ernie
to a remote location they walked Ernie
through the woods he uh was just in his
boxers he's been to the point where he's
he's just moving he he's not really uh I
don't think coherent anymore Jonathan
Sanford had had told us that his plan
was initially to shoot Ernie and then he
decided not to that he would slit his
throat and then before he had a chance
to do that Pon shot
him definitely
did okay what we need to do now oh yeah
he's dead he's not going to be alive
John the Sanford said that
he was he wasn't expecting Pon to do
that he lifted up Ernie saw that he was
dead and said something to the effect of
game over and then they left Ernie ibera
is found dead and the killers are
apprehended you might think the case is
closed not quite we're going to be you
know checking your phone records for the
last few months anybody that's involved
and this and not connected to your phone
no okay you sure about that yeah
when we
return look me in the face I need to
know the truth did you have anything to
do the's disappearance no do you have
anything to do with his death no in 2015
Texas investigators make a chilling
Discovery in the woods the dead body of
Ernie ibera a young man who was
kidnapped after a reported home invasion
police arrest three suspects Jonathan
Sanford Octavius ryes and Jose Pon
Sanford would eventually confess and
direct police to the corpse I be's wife
Samantha Wolford an aspiring YouTube
star and mother of five says despite her
marital issues with ibera she was not
involved she does admit though that she
had complained about ibera to Sanford
who by all accounts got angry with how
ibera treated her and their kids yet is
that the whole story not even close
they' got a pretty volatile pass you
we've arrested him before assaulting her
in the
infant make sure you know she didn't do
something to him and then stage the
scene to make it look like something
happened authorities note that the scene
of the home invasion is suspicious with
no items taken the kids being asleep the
entire time and the fact that
immediately after undoing her binds
Samantha called her mom first not
911 I think that Samantha wanted extra
eyes I think she wanted people to be
able to corroborate her story up to that
moment it could have happened like she
said the officers arriving on the scene
did not have any thorough understanding
of how fragile the ribbons that she was
tied up with were and it didn't have the
information regarding how she got her
phone and how she was making phone calls
where did he take that well we've got a
search one for your phone that phone's
going to be ours for a while fanger just
not piecing together with your store
it's the phone data that would reveal so
much let's go back to the body cam
footage from the night of the home
invasion they took his phone so he's got
his phone no they have his phone that's
what I'm talking about hey all right
this is what we need to do I need to do
an emergency uh phone ping and I've got
the cell phone number Chris Durant calls
A dispatch and when he's doing that she
does ask if she can call or text her
mother can I call yeah Verizon gave us
text messages from Octavius ryes phone
that showed some back and forth between
Samantha's phone and octavius's phone we
had messages from her to the
codefendants to try to help them evade
law enforcement so the first one was at
2:30 a.m. comparing uh the time stamp on
Durant's body warn camera and her asking
if she can call her mom or message her
mom at that moment she sent Octavius
Ryme a text that said to the general
effect kill day's phone shut that down
um day is a nickname that Ernie ibera
went by are they getting anything off
this they they're trying to right now so
so far nothing uh they haven't heard
back yet then there was a second message
she hears through the radio something
about an address in
Pittsburgh 86 miles from a residence in
PB know anybody in
p as he turns around she's picking up
her phone at that moment she sent
another text to Octavius ryes that said
ditch phone
move and the phone records then showed a
30se second call between her and
Octavius Rhymes just immediately after
that text messages very clearly showed
that she was The Mastermind that she was
planning this this wasn't an accident
she was an equal partner in all of this
not the innocent victim that she claimed
to be she may have been frustrated with
her life you know obviously 24-year-old
mother five children money is a con was
a constant struggle you know her husband
was working several part-time jobs I've
had a lot of people stop me and ask
about how I deal with things honestly
it's hard the had this warped way of
thinking this warped mental state that
this was going to be the way that she
got out of her relationship with Ernie
the thing is if her plan was successful
and she didn't get caught then certainly
she would be the YouTube star that she's
always wanted to be this would get her a
lot of attention and she could play
victim and I think that's what she
wanted Sanford and Pon pleaded guilty to
abducting and murdering Ernie ibera and
each were sentenced to 50 years in
prison Rhymes went to trial in two
different counties but was convicted in
both cases ultimately receiving a
combined prison sentence of 98 years as
for Wolford she also had two trials we
tried the kidnapping first what she was
trying to do is distance herself from
the uh text messages the position she
took the testimony that she gave was
that uh she had been prescribed ambian
for Sleep problems
and that she had taken an ambian and she
really didn't remember anything that
happened and didn't remember sending any
text messages the jury just didn't
believe it and they convicted her of the
aggravated kidnapping and sentenced her
to um 50 years a few months later we
tried her on the murder case in Camp
County uh and that jury gave her 99
years when the jury sees uh you know the
Ste shots from the body Canam with the
same with her on her phone at the very
same time that the phone records show
her sending text messages to the people
who you know who killed her husband
that's some solid evidence that that a
jury uh
appreciates while Wolford appealed her
cases her attempts were unsuccessful and
it seems she'll spend the rest of her
life Behind Bars I can somebody quick if
they mess with me otherwise I'm really
nice I love people I like get along with
people so well and they love me
but don't cross me because then I can be
really really mean it's
bad you know sometimes you just can't
make this stuff up even as much as you
want to for Samantha Wolford she was
looking for all the fame and attention
in the world and she definitely got her
moment in the spotlight just not how she
imagined or wanted that's all we have
for you here on Prime crime leave us
your comments on Instagram and Twitter
with the # Prime crime as always thank
you for joining us and until next time
be safe on Prime crime she said she's
having trouble breathing she said she
was stabbed multiple times it's the
attack on a young girl that left the
nation stunned as the details became
more imp parent in our investigation
it's it's extremely disturbing is a
supernatural Force to blame we think we
see in sometimes it didn't feel like
anything it was like air and what can
happen next may surprise you she poses a
significant risk of bodily harm to
herself others or to property
[Music]
hey there everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
do a deeper dive into the most
high-profile and memorable True Crime
cases you know there are a lot of
motives to kill but this one is unlike
any other what's the address your
emergency County Lum trans over caller
on Big Bend me 31st 2014 wakaa Wisconsin
a terrifying 911 phone call is about to
start one of the strangest crime stories
in modern American history Came Upon a
12-year-old female she appears to be
stabbed she appears to be what stabbed a
man named Greg Steinberg is out bicycle
riding when he discovers a young girl
bleeding on the side of the road she
says she's having trouble breathing she
said she was stabbed multiple times you
the nature of this crime scene was
particularly horrific you know our
victim was stabbed in the arms and the
legs and many times in the abdomen there
were 19 stabbing motions I mean that the
nature of this crime scene is just very
very violent the victim is Payton
Lightner she'd been attacked in the
nearby woods but was able to muster up
enough strength to crawl out she said
she can take shallow breath she's alert
and she didn't see who did this or how I
don't know I don't know if she wants to
be talking I started to asking and then
that's okay Payton is rushed to the
hospital where doctors frantically try
to save her life miraculously despite
her extensive injuries Payton survives
she missed death by millimeters I mean
one of the stab wounds just barely
missed her heart largely she lived
because those wounds were just shallow
enough that she did not have a heart
attack and die right there on the scene
hours later police apprehend the as
salance the suspects were located near
I94 where they're both taken into
custody without incident the identity of
the attackers turned out to be as
shocking as the stabbing itself two
12-year-old girls Morgan geyser and Ana
wire classmates of pton it's extremely
disturbing uh as a parent and as a chief
of
police the will to carry out this attack
means something is wildly a miss that
they would engage in that kind of
activity and commit a really aggressive
heinous crime that just doesn't happen
without there being some a red flag
indicators and B an explanation for of
some type even more frightening is why
the girls did it apparently they were
influenced by something they saw online
keeping our children safe is more
challenging now than in years past past
the internet can also be full of dark
and wicked things you said like a
character or something a character that
um is on several different websites like
a fictional character yes who was this
fictional character Ana and Morgan
decide to open up to detectives and they
say things that no one saw coming um
there's this website called of the cravy
bast Wiki it's full of like horror
stories that are meant to purposely
scare you and there's one of them called
Slender Slender Man the mysterious and
unsettling horror character depicted as
a faceless elongated figure with
multiple tendrils dressed in a dark suit
although they're in separate
interrogation rooms both Morgan and Ana
provide the same motive for trying to
kill Payton or whom they called Bella he
has these proxies or servants as people
call them
and um Morgan said hey Anisa we should
be proxies I'm like okay how would you
do that she said we have to kill
Bella
okay okay and you know why she said that
like why is she because we had to
supposedly prove ourselves worthy to
slender how many times do you think you
stabed her I don't know it happened very
quickly all I heard was
screaming I said I'm
sorry this had to happen and she was
like why and I I said that I was just it
was necessary I
can't I can't explain
why according to the girls during a
slumber party they lured Payton out to
the woods to play a game but really
intended to murder her they claimed that
if they didn't do this for Slender Man
he would kill them and their families we
think we see in sometimes okay like when
we were walking up to where to where we
were going I saw him out of the corner
of my eye on this side okay and then
Morgan said she twg crack when no one
was moving so I think there's no
question that Slender Man and their
belief in Slender Man played a role um
in their decision making on that day
even the victim was able to say that
during the time she was friends with
Morgan Morgan was quite obsessed with
Slender Man I believe at the time they
did think it's either kill Payton or our
fames going to be killed by this Slender
Man in fact after the stabbing the girls
walked about 5 hours before they were
found where were they headed s has this
big mansion that all the creepy Pastor
supposedly live in cuz she wanted to
walk to slender mhm
Morgan and Ana aren't like other
12-year-olds Morgan would be diagnosed
with schizophrenia and Ana with
delusional disorder and depression when
you put two people together that have
these you know mental challenges they
can feed off each other and I think the
fact that you had two 12-year-olds who
both had some mental disorders they
really connected and when they're
connected together like that everything
becomes more real is this a case of
mentally ill confused children who
didn't know what they were doing or
rather an excuse for a meticulous cold
premeditated act after all the girls
discussed this attack on Payton for
months beforehand the fact that this is
so incredibly
premeditated um over a 6-month period of
time makes the whole thing even more
shocking one of the plans was to
actually duct tape her mouth so she
couldn't make any noise and then stab
her out of Sleepover her and the reason
they didn't do that is they had had
skated and been out that evening and
they were tired a search of geyser's
Home revealed more there were internet
searches for how to get away with murder
and what kind of insane am I and then
there was the matter of what was found
in Morgan's room the Barbie dolls and
the notebooks and the drawings they're
so dark and they're intense and they're
Disturbed there were so many signs it
really looked like what she was
reading about drawing just sort of a a
precursor to what was going to happen
there are parts of Morgan and an's
stories that appear to line up last
thing she said was me to to me was I
trusted
you and then she said I hate you saying
stuff like I hate you guys I'll never
forgive you and I trusted you yet when
it came to actually the master
Mastermind and stabber they pointed the
finger at one
anothera told me we had to why because
she said that he'd kill our families so
back in December or January Morgan um
told you like hey we we should be
proxies same thing yeah Morgan and I
were also debating um who does the deed
at first with me but like I said I was
too screamish and said no you do it
Morgan jumped on top of Bella and
started stabbing her repeatedly and
that's when I turned around and I
couldn't stand to see that and then we
said that we were going to play hide and
seek and then he said jumped her who
stamped her first I think um and he
stapped her first and then I continued
and then like she was like margan make
sure she doesn't escape and then it was
like
uh Ana said that she'd go get help I
didn't have anything to do with the Li
that was all I
need they did blame each other in terms
of their perception of what happened and
how it happened I think they both were
just trying to be honest but they were
also both quick to say it wasn't just my
fault I didn't do this part she did that
part when we come back we're going to
take a further look into the minds of
these girls and then I didn't know what
I did it was it sort of just happened it
didn't feel like anything was like
[Music]
air so did you think that you actually
had to kill somebody to do it yeah like
for
real okay back in 2014 12-year-olds
Morgan geyser and Ana wire admit to
police that they stabbed their classmate
Payton Lightner to appease the
fictitious online character known as
Slender Man but is one more responsible
for this than the other and how exactly
should they be punished Morgan and an's
interrogation videos provided the first
glimpse into what they were thinking
while both accounts were chilling there
were startling differences Morgan was
cold Morgan seemed completely
unremorseful Morgan seemed quite
intelligent and quite manipulative she
seemed to really understand every single
thing that was happening and had no
guilt whatsoever for what she had done
we were
careless I knew this would
happen I knew we'd get in trouble why do
you think it was your sleep overnight
that your because it was we were all we
would all be together it was a Flawless
plan actually so she put the knif in
your hand and what' you doing
I
just continued
to you know what happened didn't you Ana
was a bit different Ana came off as a
12-year-old child she did express some
just a tiny level of remorse for the
decision she had made the whole time P
was screaming in
agony so we told her we were going to
get
help but we really weren't we were going
to run and let
her pass away you definitely have the
feeling I think listening to those
interviews that Morgan was more
responsible that she was the one that
actually did the stabbing that they both
said things that made it clear that they
were in this together they shared mental
disorder they shared loneliness they
shared obsession with you know you know
dark scary things and it's the
combination of the two of them that
created this event Morgan and Ana are
charged with attempted first-degree
intentional homicide in 2016 after a
lengthy legal battle making it all the
way to the court of appeals it's
determined both defendants who are then
14 years old are to be tried as adults
in this case these two girls committed
such a horrible crime that the view was
they need to be punished they tried to
kill another
12-year-old the problem with civil court
um or juvenile court is that once a
child turns 18 the courts don't have
control over that child anymore and the
concern is is that a 12-year-old um at
18 may not be ready to be out on their
own considering such a violent crime the
prosecution of these two girls for
attempted murder became a national story
with many appalled and in disbelief over
the motive yet the there were others who
felt sympathy the interrogations
themselves ignited a ton of discussion
they don't understand what it means to
be interrogated necessarily they don't
understand how they say things their
body language what they say can be used
against them and so I think there's an
inherent
unfairness do I believe regardless of my
belief that a parent should have been
there that both of them understood their
rights I think there's no question that
Morgan did Morgan is I of incredibly
High intellect she understood every
single thing that was going down that
day Ana it's a bit less clear um again a
child can understand um those rights but
I think it's it's not quite as clear
with Ana as it is with Morgan in 2017
Ana changes the game she agrees to plead
guilty to attempted second deegree
murder but she wants a trial to
determine if her mental illness excuses
her from being criminally responsible
and ultimately from winding up behind
bars the case against Ana and Morgan was
overwhelming um but one thing that was
also as far as they were concerned
overwhelming was the evidence of her
mental disease or defect the prosecution
thought that they had evidence to
establish that the mental disease or
defect did not have a huge impact on the
decisionmaking of Ana and Morgan their
position was that Ana didn't believe
some of the issues guarding Slender Man
until after the child had been stabbed a
majority of the jury would end up
agreeing with the defense and decided
that even though this was a violent
planned out crime Ana shouldn't go to
prison instead they say she needs
treatment so what they did find is by
virtue of a mental illness or mental
defect she did not have the ability to
know right from wrong you have to
realize it wasn't just one doctor or two
doctors that found that Ana had a mental
mental health issue during the time that
this crime happened there was a third
doctor that third doctor was actually a
doctor that was assigned by the court
that very same month Morgan follows suit
she pleads guilty to attempted
first-degree intentional homicide in
this agreement prosecutors don't fight
the mental illness question instead they
resolve that she should remain at a
psychiatric health facility legally she
was not held responsible and that's a
good outcome for somebody who has
committed this crime how long would
Morgan and Ana be committed to an
institution Ana was up first and at her
sentencing we learned new and Eerie
details about her from her family there
were times during our conversations
where she would look almost blank she's
talked about going to school and
becoming an advocate for children in her
situation
there have been times when she said I
don't know why I would have done
this of course a judge wants as much
information that's admissible or allowed
to be shown before making a decision of
this gravity now having said that
there's a distinction in my mind between
this is how she's acting this is how
she's helpful versus the reality of
mental health need in treatment before
the judge rendered his sentence we heard
from ANA
herself I do hold myself accountable for
this
and that I will do whatever I have to do
to make sure that I don't get any sort
of delusion or whatever again I want
everybody involved to know that I deeply
regret everything that happened that day
I'll do whatever I have you to make sure
that this doesn't happen and I know
you've heard that before and you're
probably going to hear it
again but it's the
truth and I'm sorry I think those are
great words but when you have any type
of mental health issues there's a
difference between thinking that
believing that and saying that and being
willing and able to actually follow
through with mental health treatment SRE
continues to believe that Slender Man is
real she also stated that as recently as
July
2017 she belied beli that an evil spirit
was pushing down her on her bed after
the spirit had been let out of a
homemade Ouija board she has continued
to be easily influenced by peers she has
been convinced by another inmate who was
a devil worshipper that her co-actor
meaning uh Miss geyser is possessed
what's best for the community may not be
what's best for Ana wire as much as we
can sit back and say I will never do
that again and I think it's sincere I'm
not critic criticizing her for saying it
we don't know Ana was ordered to spend
the next 25 years in a mental hospital
you know this judge recognized the
seriousness of this crime he also made
it very clear that but for the grace of
God this child would have been Dead 2
months later Morgan had her sentencing
to let Ella and her family
know I'm
sorry I
never meant this to
happen I
hope but she's doing
well it was so interesting to see Morgan
um at her sentencing and how different
she appeared than she had when she was
first interrogated after the stabbing
incident she was more emotional
remorseful now could that have been
manipulation absolutely but I took it to
be real sincere emotion for what she had
done she sounded so childlike I just
feel like her maturity to accept and
handle the consequences was different
than presented by Ana the circumstances
of the wire case are different than they
were in this case the biggest underlying
difference is the uh long history of
delusions when she saw the Slender Man
a silhouette she said she recognized
that as a man who had visited her
throughout the years when she was three
or four she poses a significant risk of
bodily harm to herself others or to
property the judge sentenced Morgan to
40 Years of institutional care Morgan
seemed to take a stronger role in
regards to what went down that day um
and the judge may have just recognized
that delineation along with the lack of
remorse that she had shown all along at
the time of this taping Morgan's lawyers
are appealing the case arguing that she
should never have been tried as an adult
Payton Lightner has moved on with her
life with plans to enter into the
medical field but that doesn't mean
she's forgotten what happened nor won't
pay attention to what happens next
legally both Morgan and Ana can now
petition every 6 months for conditional
release from the hospital with an's case
scheduled to be heard March 2021
here's the reason why I might consider
early release number one their behaviors
while they're in the facility number two
their diagnosis and treatment plan are
they able capable of maintaining a
treatment plan so that if they are
released early they can be expected not
to commit another crime both Morgan and
Ana could eventually get out keep in
mind that the judge has to make a
determination as to how dangerous
each of those individuals are in the
community one only needs to look back at
the interview particularly the interview
of Morgan anyone who watches that video
will never think it's safe to have this
girl out of a mental health
facility three lives changed Forever by
one moment it's a haunting story for
many reasons and it's one that could
have resulted in something far worse and
with legal developments still up in the
air it's a story that's still being
written that's all we have for you on
Prime crime leave us your comments on
the Slender Man stabbing on Facebook and
Twitter with the hashtag Prime crime as
always thank you for joining us and
until next time be safe